okay so the summer movie season is
officially upon us I mean a couple of
co-workers have a bet going and the bed
is which movie's gonna make the most
money this summer and I'm always down
for a good bet now for my money I'm
gonna say Toy Story 3 why because Pixar
movies always do well and Toy Story like
made Pixar yeah I'd say it's officially
the Pixar big guns and if for nothing
else never underestimate the power of
the kids movie especially in 3d so my
question for you guys is which movie do
you think is gonna be the big box office
badass this summer and why and what
movie do you think is gonna be the best
movie this summer and why and yes there
is a difference between biggest and best
in the world of movies size does not
matter but the biggest for me like I
said Toy Story 3 but for the best the
movie I'm looking forward to the movie I
think it's gonna be the coolest I got to
say inception and Christopher Nolan
actually a couple years ago he directed
this really small film I don't know if
you guys ever heard of it not many
people have the Dark Knight I am
actually convinced that Christopher
Nolan could take the X section in a
dictionary script it film it release it
it'll be the coolest movie that year I
swear to God I have yet to see a bad
Christopher Nolan movie so I have a link
in the underbar or the under box under
box what the movies coming out this
summer are so comment below and let the
world or a part of YouTube know what
your picks for the biggest movie of the
summer and the best movie of the summer
are and in the end we'll see who's right
this is gentlemen's bet by the way
there's no money involved in this
I really hope to god I beat my
co-workers though